to introduce my colleague dr. Josh
barska kasha is a expert on autism as it
appears in infants and very young
children when I first started work in
the field back in 1980 in the olden
times seeing a four-year-old was a young
child with autism and he would come see
oh come look come look four year old and
these days I think the youngest child
we've seen and were worried about for a
research project was three months and in
the clinic you think about so it's a
it's a very different situation when
it's fantastic because we think that
earlier we can intervene probably the
better the outcomes this is a very
interesting area the other thing that's
very interesting about autism as it
shows up in infants and young children
is we get to see autism as it develops
and we think that may tell us something
about about how what autism is and how
the brain is involved and what parts of
the brain are involved but also may give
us some clues for intervention as we
think about one of the things that are
thrown off so Tasha it's all yours it's
a great great pleasure as usual to be
here I have a bit of a cold so I might
be speaking a little low I can I hope
you can hear me in the back said okay so
in real life I were to hats on one hand
I'm a director of the toddler
developmental disabilities clinic so I'm
involved in a lot of clinical activities
and you will see some of that work
reflected here in this talk but I also
run a early social cognition lab in
which we study expression of autism in a
somewhat on a somewhat micro level
experimentally and asking questions how
children with autism process information
social information and particularly
information about faces so as you might
have whoops as you might have today in
this talk I'm going to talk a little bit
about the on certain diagnosis of autism
how autism expresses itself in the first
three years of life and then I'll give
you a quick preview of our work in the
lab on face processing
you might have learned thus far in this
course that autism is a complex your
developmental disorder its symptoms can
be quite severe and are expressed in two
domains primarily in social interaction
and communication children with autism
also have tremendous difficulties
without another class of problems they
have unusual sensory interest they have
some unusual body movement and quite
repetitive or stereotyped interests all
symptoms of autism become apparent in a
vast majority of cases before the third
birthday
however diagnosis is typically delayed
still in the US as Fred mentioned many
years ago a child wouldn't be diagnosed
with autism until the age of six seven
or eight right now still we do not
diagnose a majority of children until
the age of four which is a major problem
in the field autism is a pervasive
disorder it affects multiple areas of
functioning and is characterized by
incredible heterogeneity of the
expression children who are affected by
this disorder vary along a number of
dimensions including level of cognitive
ability there are some children who are
very profoundly affected in terms of
their IQ and their children who are very
bright in selected areas of Fike
functioning some children with autism
will never develop speech others are
very variable or even verbose some
children for some children our proximity
of other people is quite disturbing and
they in fact avoid contact with other
people they are quite perturbed when
being approached whereas other children
might be actually quite interested in
interacting with other children
however they have tremendous
difficulties understanding how to
navigate through this complex and
ever-changing social environment
now autism is also a developmental
disorder what does it mean well it means
that it's symptoms are changed depending
on the child's age and cognitive level
consequently if we think about the first
three years of life this is a timing
development which is incredibly dynamic
children begin newborns begin as well
regulated systems which can process a
lot of visual and auditory information
they cannot walk they cannot talk and by
the age of three and they'd not only
walk and talk but they can also cheat
and they are very sophisticated in their
understanding of the social world so it
makes a lot of sense to ask how symptoms
of autism can be expressed in a
six-month-old system versus a system
that is 18 months old or 24 months old
and for that reason we here at the Child
Study Center we've been very interested
in studying expression of autism in the
first in the first years of life not
only for diagnostic purposes not only so
we can detect these children very early
on but also so we can understand the
underlying mechanisms of social
disability and hopefully design better
treatments so that we can prevent
secondary symptoms from emerging and
perhaps even
I wouldn't say prevent autism altogether
but enhance the quality of life of
children to the extent that is beyond
imaginable right now now so as I
mentioned symptoms of autism emerge in
the first three years of life we don't
know exactly when and so at least to
address this question a few years ago we
did a small study in our clinic when we
asked parents of children who came for a
differential diagnosis with their
children
when did they begin to worry about their
child's development and now as you can
see here on the x-axis we have the age
of the child starting at birth and
ending at about to the second birthday
and as you can see the distribution of
parental age of concern is very broad
with some parents warning shortly after
birth are there's not noticing
abnormalities until after the first
birthday and still other parents saying
you know everything seems to be going
okay until almost the second birthday
now so when we look at this when this
graph a question presents itself well
why why is there such variability in the
report of the of the parental when when
parents begin to notice the first of
normalities why why there's such
variability the parents simply differ in
terms of how perceptive they are or
perhaps there's something else at play
and in fact when we reviewed literature
on onset of autism there are several
interesting things which come to the
foreground first of all there appears to
be there appears to be several patterns
of onset of autism first of all our
first one is called the early onset and
it Maps pretty well on what can I
described in his initial cases saying
that autism is innate and abnormalities
in social domain can be noticed already
within the first weeks if not months of
life however a few years later Eisen
Concannon noticed that well perhaps this
is true but also they found another
group of patients who seem to be
developing typically until the age of
let's say 18 maybe 20 months and then
gradually or suddenly they seem to lose
the words they were developing and they
seem to withdraw from the social
interaction world they call this
phenomenon a setback phenomenon or
regression and currents estimates
suggest that there might be about 15 to
30% of cases with autism who experience
this particular type of onset still if
we look a little closer the development
of children with autism we also hear
reports from parents that the child
might have developing be developing a
right until about 12 months maybe 14
months but then nothing happened as if a
child reached a certain plateau or the
development stagnated and they ceased to
acquire new new words they ceased to
acquire a new social skills and for a
long time there's nothing new happening
in development and we call it a plateau
pattern now this is quite fascinating
however I must tell you that we don't
quite understand these patterns of
growth we don't know whether these
patterns of onset are in any way
associated with let's say specific
ideological mechanisms are they
associated with a different
developmental trajectory and outcoming
these children and the reason why why
it's happening is that for many many
years in order to study the earliest
expression of autism we had to rely
almost exclusively on parent or
retrospective report or on a on
reviewing videotapes or video diaries
recorded when children were very little
and then when the child was diagnosed
with autism someone could go back and
review this diary and see whether
certain abnormality
could be apparent or not now there are a
lot of advantages to these kind of
retrospective methods but there are also
many methodological problems most of
them having to do with with selection
bias of the information we collect so
there's a new methodology around which
has become extremely popular in the past
I would say five maybe ten years this is
this is the idea of studying autism in
Staton ascending as it evolves but in
order to do that remember that we
typically do not diagnose at autism
until later in the second or third or
fourth year of life so how can we
actually study development in the first
year of life right it's it's a very
melodic question but it turns out that
genetic findings suggest that once a
child is diagnosed with autism in a
given family the recurrence risk of
autism in the same family is much
greater than we would expect in general
population as you heard autism has a
very strong genetic component and for
that reason we expect this increased
recurrence rate within the same family
the recurrence rate estimates right now
are about five to ten percent that might
change as the new studies come to
fruition it may actually go a low up but
the conservative estimate is probably
between five and ten percent now so
these younger siblings of children with
autism are at higher risk of developing
autism autism related disorders and they
also might have experienced the delays
in language cognition and social
functioning which do not meet necessary
diagnostic criteria so they provide a
very
ideal cohort to study symptoms of autism
and the mechanisms underlying it very
very early and here the L we've been
involved in this kind of study for four
years right now and I can tell you it's
an incredible undertaking in order to
find ten children with autism with me to
see 100 siblings in order to really
understand what's happening we see them
every three months starting at birth
three months six months nine months 12
months 15 months 18 months 24 months 36
months
imagine multiply it by the number of
kids the number of visit it's an
incredible incredible and enterprise but
it is very very exciting so let's talk
for a moment what we have learned thus
far from these babies of studies about
the expression of autism right then in
the first year of life I would like to
give you a little bit of a rationale why
would be even remotely looking for
symptoms of autism in the first year of
life what would be looking for what are
we looking for alright so this is like a
very brief summary what what what's
important to know about the development
in the first year of life when babies
are born they come equipped with a
number of very important perceptual
biases which helps them learn about the
world a great deal one set of these
biases has to do with priming them to
detect face-like patterns in the
environment and once they detect faces
they latch onto them they look at them
preferentially they also preferentially
enter two sources of speech speech or
language which brought together gives
them a wonderful wonderful set of skills
to find people in their immediate
environment and to attend to them this
is a great way great great opening for
learning about people and developing
more sophisticated social government
skills when we study face perception
it's a very interesting question whether
for instance in autism children might be
born without these innate perceptual
biases which would help them learn about
faces so that's one of the questions we
were pursuing in in my lab by about
three to six months infants become play
very interesting games with adults they
begin to engage in something that we
call dyadic social interaction skills so
the mom smiles the baby smiles the baby
coos mom calls the baby comes back the
reciprocity is beginning to emerge and
it's incredibly reinforcing to both
sides so you can jazz up the baby by
simply playing the game and repeating
repeating what the child is vocalizing
and smiling by six to nine months
children are beginning to show more
sophisticated skills with regard to face
processing they are not only very good
at encoding facial identity within
seconds remembering it for minutes hours
and days but they also begin to cut
eager eyes faces with regard to affect
gender and so forth they begin to
recognize certain words and respond to
them differentially in particular their
own name and the simple dyadic
anticipatory games become more
sophisticated taking shape of a peekaboo
game and so forth and so forth between
12 to 9 to 12 months several wonderful
skills begin to emerge first of all
babies monitor other people's behavior
even more intently than they do before
and they also begin to actively imitate
their behavior which is a marvelous way
about for learning new skills they also
begin to monitor faces of other people
for their facial expressions and they
derive a lot of information about the
world from what what's mom's face like
for instance if we present a child with
a new toy and the toy is a little scary
the child might look back to the mom
even
smiling on the child will approach the
toy if mom is frowning the child it's
like too likely to scoot away it's a
very important channel of again it's a
very important way of learning about the
world also at this age children begin to
communicate their needs they communicate
their needs via various vocalizations
gestures
squeals angry shouts pointing but they
also begin to communicate for another
reason they begin to communicate to
share their experiences with others by
pointing things to them showing it to
them and giving it to them we call the
set of skills our journey attention the
reason I'm mentioning all of these
skills is that many of these skills are
actually affected in toddlers and
two-year-olds with autism and the reason
why we are going back to the first year
of life that many of these skills
actually have their roots already in the
first year of life so what have we
learned about autism at six months well
I think when we all went into this
business of studying baby sips sips
we expected that by six months we'll be
able to see some symptoms of autism in
children who are later diagnosed with
autism and it doesn't seem to be so
based on the very recently published
studies from other labs
it appears that children who are later
diagnosed with autism are quite similar
with regard to eye contact affect some
very basic interaction skills as well as
a verbal and nonverbal skills and
compared to those who do not end up
developing autism and there is an
emerging consensus in the field that
these symptoms are beginning to emerge
between six and nine months further - I
intensified in a second year of
life and that's possibly just so maybe
this is just a natural course of autism
that we are we will not be able to see
anything absolutely any strong indices
of autism at six months but it is also
possible being skeptical as as we always
are it is also possible that the methods
we are using the instruments we are
using are not sensitive enough to detect
more subtle abnormalities which are
related to pathogenic factors associated
with autism and I'm going to come back
to this point in a little while when I
give you a little bit of a case study
later on so by twenty twelve months
there again emerging consensus is that
by twelve months we might begin to see
some differentiation between children
who end up being diagnosed with with
autism and those who don't some of the
important areas of impairment is
unfortunately doesn't work on this
either is the fact that children with
autism show quite limited response to
name and this is not because they don't
understand language or they have
impaired hearing there is something
about the word words there's something
about the name it's not a regular word
it actually represents a very complex
concept which is a concept of self and
children with autism have tremendous
difficulties responding when their name
is called there are reports of limited
eye contact limited use of communicative
gestures and delays in language and also
emergence of a typical the third group
of symptoms in autism emerges of a
typical way of exploring objects our
colleagues from the mind Institute
reported recently a study in which they
say that children who later are
diagnosed with autism tend to play with
objects in more a typical way spinning
them more often than other kids and also
examining them visually in a more
an intense manner than other children
but the first year of life still remains
a frontier for us when we are still very
actively studying about the symptoms and
the underlying mechanism from the
clinical standpoint we are much better
informed with regard to symptoms of
autism in the second and third year of
life a lot of work have happened in the
past three years to contribute to that
to that success when we when Fred
mentioned and in the 1980s seeing a four
year old was very unusual in the clinic
when we started a toddler clinic in the
year 2000 we were primarily seeing
referrals of children who were three or
three and a half seeing a two and a half
year old was very very early very very
unusual right now I would say the most
frequently the age of referral is around
18 to 20 months which has dropped quite
significantly in the past 10 years I'm
going to go quickly through some of the
most well known and studied symptoms of
autism in the three key areas normally I
would show you some videos we are trying
to limit the number of videos which
contain privileged information in this
particular presentation so I'm going to
describe them to you and then show you
one single case study a little later I
think one of the most striking things
that happen when you walk into the
waiting room when there are parents and
a toddler waiting to be evaluated is how
little your entry matters to this child
it takes a lot to attract the child's
attention to make them notice that you
have to enter the room
let alone to respond to a greeting
children at this age are very interested
in exploring the other environment we
see a lot of climbing a lot of exploring
toys touching them moving they often
like toys which create immediate effects
we call them cause and effect toys when
they push a button and something happens
and they can get it engage in this
activity for a prolonged period of time
to the extent that interactions or an
attempt to regain their attention can be
quite unsuccessful when we try to engage
a child in a reciprocal interaction it's
usually quite hot quite quite difficult
children might actually enjoy greatly
playing with an examiner when we show
them some interesting toy they might
enjoy the toy very much then I smile at
the toy they might stay with the toy for
a long time but there's no sense of
share activity there's very little sense
of share activity and certain enjoyment
our toddlers often make eye contact
quite often however the quality of the
eye contact is rather our typical it's
not usually it doesn't usually occur
when you expect it the most and occurs
sometimes what you don't expect it at
all it's often very fleeting and it's
not very well matched with communicative
bids and attempts to attempts to engage
someone in an interaction our children
often express experience a range of
emotion during one evaluation they can
be very happy they can be frustrated
they can be even angry however what is
striking and this is a very powerful way
of communicating
emotional states to others a very
powerful way to communicate emotional
states to others is to simply look at
someone and make the face right you
immediately communicate to mom that
there's something not quite right and
you need to help our children experience
all these emotions but they very rarely
direct them to other people they do not
communicate how they feel and which
which makes their life which makes the
world even more so isolated as I
mentioned our children with autism at
this age also have difficulty sharing
the experiences with others engaging in
journey attention and also they usually
do not monitor behaviors of others to
the extent necessary or seen in
typically developing children and they
have difficulties learning their
imitation in terms of communication it's
a very interesting area as as far as
toddlers are concerned the reason is
that most of the children we see in our
clinic at this age are primarily
nonverbal however in order to assess
their quality of communication we still
can focus on the nonverbal communication
and various aspects of
various aspects of communication having
to do with why they communicate what
kind of means they use and how well they
are integrated with social behaviors for
instance our our toddlers communicate
very infrequently a typical toddler
communicates about 3 times per minute a
child with autism might communicate
three times per half an hour now
children who do have language delays and
most of our children do have language
delays are capable of compensating for
lack of language with use of
communicative gestures expressive facial
expressions and also eye contact what we
see is in autism we see lack of these
non communicative behaviors lack of
gestures and inconsistent use of eye
contact for communicative purposes now
some of our children actually do
communicate occasionally but primarily
to get their needs met you have two
reasons why we communicate with other
people
one is to for instrumental purposes to
make them do what we want them to do and
the second we communicate in order to
share our share our experiences we call
the declarative purposes versus
instrumental purposes children with
autism can be very very effective in
communicating their needs by what we see
is this disparity in frequency of
communication for instrumental versus
declarative purposes now for those where
we see language emerging we also
unfortunately see that our typical
features of language are becoming
apparent so a child my
repeat verbatim what they just heard if
you ask them do you want juice instead
of saying yes now or nodding their head
they can repeat the one juice in with
exact inflection exact intonation we
called echolalia also there's another
very interesting feature which we see in
some not all children with autism but
when we see it it's quite specific to
autism we call this feature hand over
hand gesture if you ever come to our
clinic and you have an opportunity to
observe one of our toddlers you might be
able to see it it's quite striking when
it happens it is it is a situation in
which the child tries to communicate
what they want in order let's say they
have a container which is tightly closed
they cannot open the lid
instead of giving it to an adult with
some kind of indication that they wanted
open they might look around them they
grab the first hand they see they pull
the hand they put their hand on the
container as if they were using this
hand as a tool disembodied from from the
rest of the person it has a very
interesting feel when you are the
subject of this kind of manipulation and
and it's quite as I said we see it in
some children not all children with
autism but when we see it it's a quite
quite diagnostic sign children with
autism also have deficits in play play
early in development it's very important
for development of language and
cognition our children tend to use
objects in a typical way when they
explore objects they often focus on
physical characteristics how the object
feels how the object smells
what kind of Martin noise it can produce
or they focus on the detail
of the object this is a this is a
picture of a little boy who is relaxed -
lined up his toys and and that might be
one of the primary modes of display now
in young children we see some of the
repetitive and interest repetitive
behaviors and unusual sensory interests
as well some children might be overly
sensitive to touch or might be very
interested in our certain types of
motions so we've had children toddlers
who can spin pretty much anything from
their shoe plate lead pencil anything
some children also have experienced
develop interesting unusual activities
or unusual objects in this case we have
a little toddler who likes cans and
likes can cans we are also at this age
beginning to just beginning to see the
emergence of unusual motor behaviors and
hand mannerisms but these behaviors in
this group are usually are not very
pronounced can be not do not have to be
very pronounced in the second year of
life now autism is not only about
deficits but also about some excesses
and you might have heard that some
children with autism have actually quite
exceptional abilities this phenomenon
was for the first time described by dr.
John Langdon down who noticed that some
children with very profound
developmental delays my might have a
specific ability in a very in a one
isolated area and disability might have
to do with exceptional memory musical
skills artistic skills computation
ability
it's usually isolated from our other
skills here I pulled a drawing by
Stephen Wiltshire who has unbelievable
visual memory skills and drawing skills
here he's drawing I think it's a
panorama of Tokyo after a very brief
flight over the city I would encourage
you to go to his web site and actually
see a few videos file these drawings are
produced when we think about toddlers we
don't really see a lot of exceptional
abilities although some of our toddlers
are very interested in learning about
letters numbers some begin to sight-read
they can recognize signs stops exits
find them everywhere read them out loud
those who are verbal might have a very
good expressive vocabulary they might
like to label objects they might have
actually quite extensive vocabulary for
their age and some of the toddlers we
see have great memory for movies or
books and they can recite them verbatim
presence of these kind of skills often
my-delay a diagnosis because parents of
an 18 month old who is interested in
their ABCs and can recites recognize all
the letters of the alphabet parents of a
child like that might overlook the fact
that this is the same child might not be
interested in interacting with other
people and a might not be using
functionally on any of the language
skills he or she has nonetheless we see
these skills in some children not all
children with autism they tend to be
isolated not integrated with social
interaction or more sophisticated play
they tend to be repetitive children who
like letters will gravitate toward
letters they will not play with dolls
and in many kids they are transient they
do not develop in special interests on
unusual abilities I think in my clinical
practice I've
only a few children who went on to
develop special skills one of them was a
little boy who I saw maybe at 20 months
who really loved shapes he could label
any shape show him any shapes she/he
would see a table as a rectangle every
every almost every object was reduced to
a shape which then he could label it
turns out that by the age of five or six
he stopped being interested in in shapes
but he developed interest in train
schedules and and routes of the metro
system so so what do we do with all this
information we now we have an idea what
the autism might look like in a second
year of life and then a child presents
in the clinic for a differential
diagnosis and what do we do how do we go
about it
well rule number one is we step very
very lightly it's a very serious
disorder it's diagnosing a child with
autism is extremely it's highly
consequential for the life of this child
and the family and for that reason we
take this diagnostic process extremely
seriously each child is seen in our
clinic for for two day evaluation we
bring on board three four sometimes more
disciplines in order to better
understand understand the child's
clinical presentation and be able to
sort out what might be driving the
difficulties we see here I'm listening
for your information
an example of a battery of tests we
would employ for an 18 month old baby as
you can see a large portion of it
involve interviewing parents taking very
detailed medical developmental history
understanding whether there were any
factors in the child's development which
might potentially account for the
difficulties we are seeing we interview
parents using divine and adaptive
behavior scales to understand better
what is the child's presentation at home
we can take a snapshot of the child's
presentation in the clinic but we want
to understand how the parents perceive a
child at home what are the skills that
the child demonstrates in the optimal
environment we also usually have two or
three clinicians interacting with the
child the reason is we want to introduce
different people to the child because
each of us brings a different style and
we want to understand whether the
observations we see are consistent
across contexts or maybe they are
context specific maybe one of us had
something very special that we were
we're not able to wear or not able to
elicit from the child in order to
diagnose a child with a such severe
developmental disorder we need to
understand the child's developmental
functioning in verbal and nonverbal
domains against to see whether there
might be any factors which contribute to
the child's social difficulties we study
their nonverbal communication very
carefully and also subject' the
childhood play session semi-structured
play session which helps us evaluate the
child's spontaneous level of social
interaction and communication only when
we have all these bits and pieces of
information we can get together with all
the clinician and begin to discuss what
the diagnosis might be
also at the end of this process we have
a lot of information about the child and
not only important for diagnostic
purposes but also important for
treatment planning for a given child as
I mentioned diagnosis is a very serious
issue at this age and when we started
running this clinic we were asking the
same question how stable this diagnosis
is if we see a child at 18 months 20
months the child's presentation is
consistent with the diagnosis of autism
how likely it is that this child will
still present as a child with autism
five years later and we conducted a
couple of studies here at the clinic and
appears that the stability of the
diagnosis between 2 and 4 is relatively
high and our colleagues in other centers
also report as similar similar findings
which is quite encouraging which means
that we actually can predict some extent
diagnostic status of these children
however there's a huge variability
children move a lot within the spectrum
I just wanted to mention to your study
which is just came out this month in
which we took a fairly large group of
children 90 almost 90 children who are
presenting for differential diagnosis
before their second birthday and we
evaluated them very carefully and
diagnosed some of them with autism some
of them with the pervasive developmental
disorder not otherwise specified which
is
which is a residual diagnostic category
indicated that the child has some social
difficulties but not as severe as autism
and another group was diagnosed with a
non autistic disorders having to do with
nonspecific developmental delays or
language delays and then when we follow
them up at the age of three we saw that
actually none of these children
initially diagnosed with ASD converted
to a non is the category which means
that we were pretty good at detecting
autism when he was there
however we also found a quite a lot of
movement within that within the autism
spectrum so there were about 25 percent
of children who presented with very
severe symptoms early on and by the age
of three or four their symptoms improved
markedly we see a movement in the other
direction as well so before before I
talk a little bit more about face
processing I would like to tell you a
little bit about a case study which
might illustrate some of the points I
made with regard to early expression of
the syndrome this is a low girl whom who
is a younger sibling of a child with
autism and we had a privilege to follow
her development starting at six months
through her third birthday and
unfortunately she she is one of the
children who ended up developing an
autism spectrum disorder and by studying
her development we are learning quite a
lot about how the disorder unfolds I'm
going to show you a very very
superficial just a few things about her
development as we are still working on
the day
so in this slide we summarize her
development in the verbal and nonverbal
domains and on the y-axis you have age
which we saw her for the evaluation six
months 12 18 24 and 36 and on the y-axis
you see the mental age or age equivalent
score on the small and scale of early
learning from which these scores are
derived okay and as you can see both her
verbal and nonverbal skills are
progressing quite nicely right at six
months she was right at the level of 12
months she was right on target 18 months
we begin some differentiation between
her verbal and nonverbal skills she was
very verbal her verbal skills are quite
advanced and by 36 months if anything
she's more advanced than her peers right
her scores are higher than we would
expect higher than 36 months so just
looking at her cognitive and verbal
skills we would have absolutely no
reason to be concerned about her
development
however we were also tracking very
closely her development in social domain
which is the diagnostic domain for us in
this case and we in order to study that
we use the autism diagnostic observation
schedule this was a toddler version and
we have two domains in which we assess
the child's functioning social effect
and repetitive behaviors and the way the
scale is designed at the higher score
denotes greater degree of
psychopathology and as you can see at
the age of 15 months she was doing just
fine sir very low scores
nothing nothing going on on this
particular scale however something
terrible has happened in here between 15
and
18 and then 24 months because we see
mark the deficits development of mark
deficits in terms of social
communication use of eye contact
effective communication and so forth so
this is just looking at this graph we
might say you know this is when autism
begins to develop in this slow girl we
also see some increase in repetitive
behaviors it's the slope is much lower
because the range is also lower smaller
and she did not have a lot of therapies
this pact of this despite the fact of
the mark social disability I wanted to
show you one more graph because it
illustrates some of the special
abilities we often see in toddlers so
this scale comes from the vine and
adaptive behavior skills and I pictured
here for you the results from the
communication scale it's a parent
interview and communication scale
captures are the child's receptive and
expressive language but it also taps
into the area of written communication
and as you can see in terms of receptive
expressive language the girl is
progressing over time just fine as we
would expect based on her cognitive
scores however look at the verbal
written domain unbelievable jump are
happening at 18 months to define that at
the age of three she functions more like
a four and a half of five-year-old and
that particular jump reflects the
special ability in her case which has to
do with her interest with reading early
reading and decoding she's probably
developing hyperlexia and I think she
might become a good subject for Jamy
studies in the future future so so we
might just end at that point but when we
saw her 24 months and 18 months and when
we saw this big jump in terms of the
emergence of symptoms of autism we went
back to the recording of the sessions we
saw
at six and nine months and I also went
back also to notes of the clinicians who
are seeing her at that point and we
noted that there were some difficulties
or some unusual behaviors which we
didn't know quite how to categorize
however there were some some things that
were no unusual so the way we study six
social development in six or nine month
olds is we subject them to a series of
so-called social probes in this
particular probe research assistant is
sitting across from the baby and talks
in mother East you know what mother is
is right high pitch baby directed talk
and she needs to stay there for about
two men a minute or two and talk to the
baby and we record how babies respond
and in this case we have a six month or
who is typically developing and
and it's totally mesmerised this is nine
months
so so in this particular case we were
typically developing baby motherese at
six-month the babies mesmerize there are
some smiles which she tried to insert in
the in the in the research assistants
utterances by nine months she's becoming
much more active Shira Frances her mom
she's having lots of fun she fully
appreciates and enjoys this kind of
interaction this is another girl this is
the girl we just talked about at six
months
that's nine months
and in this case we see much less of
this effect of share enjoyment with the
with the research assistant there's a
lot of turning twisting body away from
the person who is trying to interact
with her and we saw this pattern
repeatedly at 6 9 12 and 15 months which
might suggest there might be some more
subtle signs in terms of expression of
the social difficulties and we are
working quite intently on categorizing
these signs or detecting the patterns
which might differentiate children who
later develop autism already at 6 and
perhaps even three months we also apart
from using these behavioral techniques
in which we put a child into a room with
an adult and we have them interact and
we record their responses in a context
of a life interaction we also are trying
to study their social cognition using
somewhat different approaches and I
would like to talk to tell you a little
bit about the eye tracking research we
do in our lab babies cannot do a lot of
things they cannot walk they cannot talk
they cannot press the bar to tell us
what the reaction time is going to be to
certain classes of stimuli and but they
can watch things they can look and
actually vision is visual perception is
one of the most important apart from
from auditory modality it's one of the
most important sources of information
about the world starting from the very
beginning we know that scanning patterns
our visual scenes are non-random they're
goal-oriented they are exploratory
behaviors and they are affected by a
number of factors which are important
always important to consider when we
study visual cognition using eye
tracking scanning patterns are affected
by the perceptual properties of the
scene having to do with motion high
contrast areas color sudden onset of the
stimuli they are very likely to attract
our attention but they are also driven
to a large extent by the semantic
properties of the visual scene what we
know what the perceiver knows or thinks
and feels about the perceived scene with
regard to faces a very simple example is
that we scan faces of people we know
very well quite differently then we scan
faces of strangers also evidence from
developmental science suggests that
scanning patters are likely to be
affected by age they change with age and
also studies on other disorders besides
autism suggests that they can be
affected by my friend sess schizophrenia
bipolar disorder as well as autism so in
my lab we are quite interested in a
number of phenomena associated with face
perception and in this particular study
we have a 6-month er who is engaged in
face recognition study we are asking
this little baby to encode an identity
of a new face and then we test her on
what she's learned using so called
visual paired comparison paradigm you
might be able to see this red dot here I
don't know if you can see it with the
lights on but this is her point of
regard
and she's a marvelous
look ER they're attentive little baby
and here we asked her to compare the
familiar face in the normal face and
that's pretty much and of the first
phase of the experiment what we do with
this kind of data we can summarize it
globally by where the child is looking
these are a summary of her scan pads
over this face you just saw and as you
can see as in a typical six month er
she's not very she's not terribly
adventurous in terms of face scanning
she spends a lot of time looking at the
eyes in a static image of the face just
to give you an idea what kind of studies
can be done or what we're doing in our
lab in terms of face book scanning in
infancy we are interested for instance
how face scanning changes depending on
the context in which faces are in which
faces are presented and in this
particular study we had a cohort of
children fall from 3 6 9 and 12 months
and we showed them three kinds of faces
in one case it was a static face pretty
much like the one you just saw
before in another case in another
condition it was a image it was a movie
of a fete of a person smiling so the
dynamic stimulus there was no speech but
there was motion and effect and then we
had another movie in which there was
some motion but the person was reciting
a nursery rhyme and what was very
interesting to find is that children
actually adjust their scanning strategy
depending on what kind of faces they are
looking at so they're looking at the
static face most of the attention is
distributed toward the eyes as compared
to the to the mouths of the person and
it's true about of three month or six
months nine months and twelve months
when we look at the smiling face that
distribution changes somewhat attention
to mouth increases attention to eye
decreases a little bit with the idea is
that in order to read the emotion you
need to get information both both from
the mouth and also from the eyes to
truly appreciate what is the person's
effective expression things with even
more complicated when we show babies
faces they are talking because starting
at 6 months in this case they begin to
actually scan the mouth area more
frequently than the eyes especially when
they're six and nine months old which we
hypothesize helps them understand speech
there's a lot of nice perceptual cues in
the way the mouth moves when we
pronounce words which provides provides
some visual input and support for
understanding language so so these are
only typical babies we will be mapping
children who are developing autism onto
these normative data to try understand
how much sensitivity we see in that
cohort with regards to the types of
faces children are experiencing now I
have no word so I have out by 5:30 we
have still some time left yeah all right
so at the end I would like to talk a
little bit about studies on face
processing that we conducted on toddlers
we have catalogued pretty well the
behavior symptoms of autism we know
about your attention we know about
deficits in dyadic social interaction we
know what kind of repetitive behaviors
we can expect in children with autism
but symptoms of autism pervade autism
pervades also other areas of functioning
and one of the areas of functioning it
affects is face
Singh and from studies of all their
children and adults with autism we now
that they have difficulties in face
recognition they appear to employ
different ways processing strategies
which might be less effective resulting
in difficulties in face recognition and
also when they look at faces they
recruit different neural somewhat
different neural mechanisms to learn
about them and to remember to process
them and remember them now most of these
studies were conducted on adults and
school-aged children with autism what is
actually interesting about faces that
face processing is develops over a very
prolonged period of time start starting
at birth and reaching adult stages
sometimes somewhere in mid teens and
what we what we've learned thus far
about face processing in autism we've
learned in a way looking at the certain
developmental endpoint and in order for
us what's very fascinating and very very
interesting to know is not only what the
endpoint is but how the children get
there and what were the initial states
of their face processing system whether
these deficits were primary or secondary
do they emerge sometimes within within
the first years of life or they're
present there very shortly after birth
so with this question in mind we said we
conducted several studies on first
processing in toddlers trying to see
whether certain abnormalities can be
seen already in the second year of life
the first question the first study I
would like to talk to you about is study
in which we
examined the recognition and also
scanning strategies in this study we had
two groups of toddlers actually four
groups of toddlers two groups were
diagnosed with autism spectrum disorder
and the other two groups were typically
developing and younger children or about
two and a half years old and the older
children were about four we tested them
in a visual paired comparison paradigm
in which first they were presented with
the novel face very much like the girl
you saw on the veneer a moment ago they
were allowed to look at this face for as
long as ten seconds and then we showed
them an familiar face paired with a
novel face and the way our visual system
is a cognitive system is designed once
we learn about something or habituated
to something we tend to look at
something new so the measure of
recognition is a ratio of the amount of
time spent looking at the novel face as
compared to the familiar face and the
way we process this data we divide this
visual scene in this case a face into
regions of interest and these are the
key features facial features eyes nose
and mouth which then can be combined
into the inner features and we also
consider other features which have to do
with the forehead cheek cheeks chin and
hair
these are the other features and
everything else is a non face or
background and we were very very
surprised to some extent by these
results but
also quite encouraged to see that there
are differences between groups how these
can faces
first of all this these graphs are low
complicated so let me walk you through
them we analyzed data on two levels one
level was the group features inner
features which includes eyes mouth and
nose other features hair and other
facial areas and that's the background
in the second analysis we zeroed in on
the inner features looking at the eyes
mouth and nose and I would like you to
first look at the yellow and orange bars
right here which represent our typical
controls two-year-olds in yellow and in
orange we have our four-year-olds and
there's one striking feature there what
was that what's that
there's no age differences right there
the bars identical regardless of the age
which suggests that between the age of
two and four children typically
developing children have settled on a
certain scanning strategy and it doesn't
change between these ages they tend to
look a lot of inner features a little
bit without the features of the face and
once we consider the key features of the
face they look a lot the eyes and spend
about half of the time they look at the
eyes looking at the mouth however when
we look at the children with autism we
see several important effects some of
the effects have to do with what happens
when children grow older and here we see
a few concerning trends one concerning
trend is as these children grow older
they spend less time looking at the key
features of the face instead they begin
to look away at the background so in
some ways we see worsening of their
scanning patterns as they grow older
when we look at the internal features of
the face we see one interesting finding
which is that children with autism
actually look less at the mouth and then
typically developing children in these
images and I'm going to
finding in a moment we also see a trend
of diminishing attention to the eyes as
children grow older but this was not
significant now when we looked at their
recognition scores in terms of how well
they recognized a new face it turns out
the typical children as expected have
had no difficulties including facial
identity and recognizing an oval face
familiar face however our children with
autism perform at the chance level so
similarly as their older counterparts
reported in studies and school aged
children they also have difficulties in
encoding facial identity we are also
interested whether there is an
association between how they look at the
face and what they learn about it
so we examine their scanning patterns
during familiarize ation with the
performance during the recognition test
and it turns out that more restricted
scanning pattern more looking at the
eyes at the expense of looking at the
other important features which encode
fashion identity resulted in more poor
performance on this particular test so
for some of you there might be a
question of hearing whether perhaps
children with autism have difficulties
in general with processing information
and learning about new things and so we
wanted to make sure that the deficits we
see here i in fact face specific so in
order to do it we took 19 toddlers with
autism spectrum disorder and we run them
on the two conditions one involving
faces just the one the same as you saw
before and in the second condition we
use objects instead of faces and as you
can see here they show the nice
novelty preference for Freight for
objects but not for faces so this
deficit in encoding identity appears to
be specific to faces at least at this
point so another aspect of face
processing has to do with regulation of
attention it's what happens before we
actually engage in active exploration of
the face so in a very recent study we
asked a question whether there might be
some deficit in face processing on other
levels and recognition on attentional
level faces are a very special belong to
a very special very privileged class of
stimuli they are detected much faster
than other objects so if we present a
face in an array of objects you are much
likely to much faster to detect face
than another object look you're looking
for and once we detect the face our
attention seemed to be held by the face
much more strongly that than by any
other object in this respect we talked
about an increased cost of disengagement
from a face that we see in typical
individuals and this increased cost is
usually expressed in increased reaction
time to peripheral targets now from one
of the previous studies we had an
accidental finding which suggested that
this
attentional processing of faces in
autism might be affected but in this
particular studies we wanted to develop
a more in-depth understanding of this
phenomenon children were tested in
something that we call overlap attention
queuing paradigm I'm going to show in a
moment what it looks like we enrolled
groups of children with autism
developmental delay and typical controls
and we studied their psychotic reaction
time the way we did it is following it's
a very simple experiment extremely
simple in the non social condition we
showed them this kind of mosaic in the
center of the screen it's a scrambled
face okay and then after a second or so
a peripheral target appeared either on
the left or right of this particular
central cue what we were interested is
how much time is it going to take them
to initiate eyed movement over the
target in other words we're interested
in psychotic reaction time psychotic
reaction time is composed of several
components involved with planning a
saccade computing psychotic parameters
where you're gonna go and disengaging
attention from the current fixation
point so the more you are engaged with
the stimulus the longer the reaction
time is likely to be so we tested them
in a non social condition and then we
created a couple of social conditions in
this case this lady is doing all sorts
of things with her eyes and then the
target appears we make her blink her
eyes and move her eyes to make her more
salient more attractive rather than just
a static picture you noticed that when
we started this display she was looking
straight at the camera in the second
condition we never let her look at the
camera
with the idea that faces with direct
gaze might have even more stronger
attentional hold on typical individuals
we expected the typically developing
children and children without autism
will have greater difficulties
disengaging from these two classes of
the stimuli than children with autism
and we expected that in the non social
condition all the groups will be
equivalent and lo and behold this is
exactly what we saw
as you can see in non social condition
all the children are the same and in the
social condition regardless of the
direction of gaze we see reaction time
much shorter in the autism group which
suggests that their attention was not
encumbered by the social quality of this
particular stimulus so based on the
study we concluded that faces do not
elicit the same attentional bias in
toddlers with autism as they do with
children without social disability and
this effect seem to be autism specific
because we did not see it in children
with our other cognitive impairments so
the question arose why why is that so
why would they be really disconnecting
so fast from the face
well one hypothesis was that perhaps
they are just faster at processing
visual stimuli so they didn't don't have
to look at them so long because they
encode them very rapidly and it is quite
unlikely that the speed of processing
would be responsible for the current
pattern of results because as our
previous studies showed that they
despite the fact that they are looking
at the faces they have poor recognition
skills so it's not that they are
processing the identity faster and they
move away from the face there's likely
something else
so the second hypothesis which we are
pursuing now testing directly in my lab
has to do with depth of processing it
turns out that anytime we look at any
kind of stimulus including a face we can
engage variety of levels of processing
or at least couple of levels of
processing so if we look at the face we
can look at the face almost as an object
and think about its its physical or
perceptual properties we might think
about categorizing it is it the face or
this is not face is it a male is it a
female is it a redhead or is it a
brunette
at that level we do not engage in a lot
of processing of a semantic kind however
if we look at the face we can also begin
to think well is this someone I know
this reminds me of X Y & Z well this
person is really trustworthy
I would like to probably meet this
person or no I would never ever ever
would like to come close to that person
in my life and it turns out that
depending on what kind of level we
engage with with the face that the level
within which we engage with the face
actually affect how well we encode
facial identity so adults subjected this
kind of manipulation have difficulties
recognizing a face once they were asked
to focus on physical characteristics if
they were asked to focus on more
semantic characteristics their
performance was greatly improved so we
hypothesized that it is possible then
when a when a child with autism looks of
the face
they might not engage with the face on
the same level as children without
autism they might be looking at the face
they might be focused on perceptual
features of the face maybe doing simple
computations having to do with assessing
its gender or faceless and and not
necessarily thinking is mom is it nice
and so forth so these are the hypothesis
we are currently examining in in our lab
so just to sum up quickly only a few
minutes for questions
the studies on phase processing in
toddlers thus far show that they have a
typical abnormalities biases in terms of
phases deficits in face recognition that
the properties of their scanning in
particular restricted scanning patterns
might be responsible for less effective
encoding and also we are noticing very
concerning trend suggesting that the
face scanning might become more abnormal
as children grow older the next
questions questions very important for
us are whether these deficits are
primary or secondary can we see them in
the first year of life and we are also
studying other aspects of face
processing which might tell us a little
bit more about the patterns of strengths
and weaknesses that children with autism
have in this particular area and by that
tell us a little bit more about the
underlying mechanisms the long term goal
and fantasy of people in my lab is that
perhaps we can also design techniques to
help children normalize their face
processing skills but that's something
that it's sort of far far far away in
terms of an expression of autism are
just a few words symptoms are typically
apparent already in the second year of
life to the extent that they can be
detected quantified and used reliably
for diagnosing children these symptoms
can be the diagnosis itself is
relatively stable but we do see
tremendous variability in how the
syndrome expresses itself in the first
year of life and second year of life
actually and
what are the outcomes with Samsung
making tremendous amount of progress and
other children making relatively low
progress the concerning part is that we
do not understand basis of this
heterogeneity and one of the very
important goals which we are working
toward and other colleagues around the
country are working toward is to
understand to parents this heterogeneity
and understand its underlying mechanism
and I wanted to thank you for your
attention and see if you have any
questions